♪ ♪
>> Jonathan: AS WE MENTIONED
EARLIER IN OUR SPECIAL
BROADCAST, THE STATE FUNERAL OF
QUEEN ELIZABETH II HAS BROUGHT
TOGETHER MORE THAN 2,000 HEADS
OF STATES AND DIGNITARIES FROM
AROUND THE GLOBE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND FIRST LADY
DR. JILL BIDEN ARE AMONG THEM.
YESTERDAY, THE FIRST COUPLE
VISITED WESTMINSTER HALL WHERE
THE LATE MONARCH LYING IN STATE
SINCE LAST WEDNESDAY.
THE ROSTER OF VIPs ATTENDING
THIS MORNING'S FUNERAL, WE BRING
IN FOX NEWS ROYAL CONTRIBUTOR.
SUCH A PLEASURE TO HELP YOU WITH
US HERE.
AND TO SIT ALONGSIDE YOU FOR
SUCH A MOMENTOUS OCCASION.
I CANNOT THINK OF ANYBODY ELSE
IN THE WORLD WHO COULD HAVE
BROUGHT TOGETHER SO MANY HEADS
OF STATE TO PRINCES AND
PRINCESSES IS, WHAT IS IT ABOUT
THE QUEEN THAT JUST MAKES
EVERYBODY WANT TO BE HERE TODAY?
>> IT IS RESPECT.
I THINK PEOPLE REALLY RESPECTED
HER.
ALL THE CROWNS INTERVIEWED TODAY
AND ALL HAVE THAT ONE SYMMETRY
THAT THEY LOVED HER AND THEY
RESPECTED HER AND THEY FELT THAT
SHE HAD GIVEN UP HER PERSONAL
HAPPINESS FOR DUTY, A RARITY IN
THIS DAY AND AGE COMPLETELY.
>> Jonathan: WHILE WE ARE ON
THE SUBJECT OF DUTY, DO YOU
THINK KING CHARLES HAS THE SAME
SENSE OF DUTY, ONE, AND SECONDLY
THE ABILITY TO PULL IT OFF LIKE
THE QUEEN DID?
>> YES, I THINK HE HAS EXACTLY
THE SAME SENSE OF DUTY.
HE HAS MADE MISTAKES IN HIS
LIFE, SOME VERY BIG MISTAKES,
BUT HE HAS THAT DUTY.
THAT IS WHAT HE DOES.
EVEN WHEN HIS WIFE QUEEN CONSULT
TALKS ABOUT HIM SHE SAID HE IS A
WORKAHOLIC AND NEVER STOPS.
HE HAS ALWAYS SAID THAT HE CARES
SO MUCH.
I CARE TOO MUCH.
HE CARES ABOUT ALL OF THOSE AND
HE CARES ABOUT THE WORLD ANY
CARES ABOUT THE CLIMATE.
YES, ONE, AND TWO, HE DOES HAVE
THE ABILITY, HE'S GOT A HUGE
ENERGY AND ALL THOSE WINDSOR
PLURALISTS THEY YOUNG WHEN THEY
WERE YOUNGER AND NEVER WALKED
DOWN CORRIDORS.
AND I THINK CHARLES HAS THAT
ENERGY AND THAT DEDICATION.
>> Jonathan: HE WILL BE
WATCHED SO CLOSELY AND HAS TO
AVOID ANY MISTAKES.
ONE OF THE MISTAKES EVERYBODY
WAS WATCHING FOR THIS TIME WAS
WHO WILL BE IN AND WHO WILL BE
OUT ON THIS INVITE LIST.
OBVIOUSLY, WE SAW
PRESIDENT BIDEN HE IS HERE,
JUSTIN TRUDEAU FROM CANADA, THE
AUSTRALIAN PRIME MINISTER AND
ALSO NOT INVITED VLADIMIR PUTIN
OF RUSSIA FOR OBVIOUS REASONS,
KIM JONG UN OF NORTH KOREA, AND
SYRIA.
NOT FUN TO HAVE TO DRAW UP THAT
LIST WHEREAS DUNCAN WAS SAYING
EARLIER A SEATING CHART FOR ALL
OF THIS.
>> LUCKILY, THE KING DOESN'T
HAVE TO DO THAT.
HE'S GOT GOOD PEOPLE.
AND SO, THE EUROPEAN ROYAL
FAMILIES THE LATE QUEEN RELATED
TO MANY OF THE ROYAL FAMILIES OF
EUROPE.
YOU HAVE THE KING OF SWEDEN.
WE HAVE THE KING OF SPAIN, THE
ROYAL FAMILY OF MONACO, THE
NETHERLANDS, THE WILLIAM OF
ORANGE.
AND ALL RELATED.
AND I THINK THEY PLAY AN
IMPORTANT PART AS WELL.
THEY ARE A LITTLE MORE
RECOGNIZABLE THAN PERHAPS THE
HEADS OF STATE IN SUITS.
I THINK A LITTLE MORE COLORFUL.
ALSO, CARLOS, A DISGRACED FATHER
OF -- SORRY, KING PHILIP.
HE WAS INVITED TO COME UP WITHIN
THE SPANISH GOVERNMENT SAID,
"NO, NO, NO, YOU ARE TOO
CONTROVERSIAL AND IN TROUBLE."
HE CAME ANYWAY.
>> Jonathan: YOU TALK ABOUT
THE ROYAL FAMILIES BUT ANYBODY,
WHETHER IN THE PHILIPPINES OR IN
AUSTRALIA OR IN KENYA, YOU SAY
THE QUEEN, IT WAS THE QUEEN.
SHE WAS THE ONLY ROYAL THAT
EVERYBODY IN THE ROYAL SEEM TO
KNOW.
>> FOR OBVIOUS REASONS.
EVERYBODY IN THE WORLD EVEN FOR
THE YOUNGEST OF THE YOUNGEST
CHILDREN, THEY RECOGNIZE THE
QUEEN.
>> Jonathan: SUCH A PLEA